Jennifer Lawrence is ready to take a  break from acting does he never know  what's gonna happen in society to accept  you you can't even accept yourself from  x-men to Hunger Games the oscar-winning  actress has made her mark on the big  screen over the years yeah I'm trying  but after filming an average of three  movies a year  Jayla revealed in a new interview with  Elle magazine she would like to take  some time off from showbiz to return to  her country roots quote I want to get a  farm I want to be like milk and goats my  name is Jennifer and these are my issues  while the Kentucky native plans to take  up more agricultural hobbies in the  future fans can look forward to seeing  her play a spy in her movie red sparrow  in 2018 color sparrows that's what she  is  [Music]  you